one more project that i would like to
leave you with that is what i am
planning to do next and i haven't yet
talked about this this is the first time
that i am saying anything at all about
it
what i am planning to do is
to
create a calendar
there are a lot of those there's the
gregorian calendar
for example
and the calendars that we have are
very regular
they are more regular than the spin of
the planet they're certainly more
regular than life on earth
and so that got me thinking about
whether you could have a different kind
of a calendar a calendar that would in
fact be true to life in terms of the
fact that it would keep time according
to how life was lived on this planet
well those calendars are actually all
around us they're called trees and trees
will grow a ring every year and the
girth of that ring is determined by
climate by
rainfall weather patterns and so forth
but we don't tend to see them in that
way unless we saw them down
and
to me it seems that you could in fact
make a tree operate as a calendar by
taking that tree and i am proposing a
bristle cone pine a tree with a 5 000
year life span and putting milestones
around it well not exactly milestones
but
century stones or stones with a 500 year
period between stones set at regular
intervals according to
if the calendar if the tree were to grow
at the rate that it is right now where
would it be in 500 years at that point
it will grow large enough that because
of its strength it will turn over that
stone and a thousand years and so forth
up to five thousand but of course
it will fall out of sync it won't it
won't work out that that 500 years will
be the same 500 years as you have marked
on your gregorian calendar and
to me that is where it really gets
interesting because i don't know which
calendar in that case we would say was
right i don't know how we would
account for time if we had these two
different kinds of calendars that were
simultaneously keeping time one of which
was celestial one of which was abstract
and the other which was manifest
manifestly terrestrial and was really
about the world as we exist in it the
world in which we are living in now
so
where to get a bristle cone pine
well it just so happens that i know some
people who have more than one of them
the long now foundation happens to have
this space
more than a space it's 800 odd acres in
eastern nevada mount washington they
bought it back in the 90s and it just so
happens to have
the world's largest bristlecone pine
forest in private hands
this is the ideal space and i've already
started talking with the long now
foundation about how we might implement
this to put the calendar there that we
would be able for the next five and five
thousand years to keep time on our
planet
[Music]
you